traces of a significant past Kamal
Micallef is proud of the Islamic legacy
of Andalusia he is Algerian himself but
came to Cordoba 30 years ago this city
played an important role in the Middle
Ages and was a significant Islamic
Center I would say that not only Muslims
but everyone is proud of Islamic
civilization in Spain but not everyone
would agree for the far-right Vox party
which won 11 percent of the votes in
regional elections last year Spain's
Muslim past and present pose a danger
the party chairman warned of a new Arab
invasion in an online video religious
and artistic heritage is being
threatened by money from radical Islamic
countries but we didn't reconquer Spain
for nothing construction of the Great
Mosque of Cordoba began in the eighth
century but its centre was converted
into a Catholic Church during the
Reconquista Muslims are currently not
allowed to pray in the complex
today's Muslim community which is a
minority prays at a mosque on the
outskirts of the city Kemal Micallef is
the president of the Muslim Association
of Cordoba he's concerned that the
far-right Vox party now has 12 seats in
parliament these people don't want to
acknowledge the Magnificent legacy that
Islam has left here is Lama a la
historia de theater
these are the ruins of the Caliphate
city of Medina as a hardier which was
listed as a UNESCO World Heritage Site
last year excavation and restoration
continue here but they are costly the
director Alberto montejo is trying to
raise funds in Arab states Cordoba and
Medina is a ha real reference for the
Arab world we're in contact with the
embassies of Arab States and we're
trying to explore what form of support
they could offer our work far-right
extremists are angry about this but
nobody would say this in front of the
camera we asked some of the Vox party's
sympathizers what they thought mari
valia de lara fears that spain is
becoming dependent on rich Arabs they're
invading Europe they don't want to
accept defeat and we're just watching
that annoys me on the one hand we say
this is Spain Europe and on the other
we're just accepting the border to shift
at the Pyrenees it's all about the money
Pepe Lopez the owner of this store which
sells religious articles also voted for
Vox she's a staunch advocate of the
unity of the Catholic Church and Spain
she argues that this is threatened by
Muslims both poor refugees and rich
benefactors
to me they probably want the cathedral
back it used to be their mosque but it's
not only an Arab building Christian's
completed it the majority of Andalusia
pne's do not share these views but they
are becoming more mainstream the UNESCO
World Heritage Sites director Alberto
Montejo says that it's important to
point out how the Moors
enriched Spain Islam was here for over
800 years and it left significant traces
in nature in our way of being in a food
the language we cannot ignore this for
Kemal Micallef it is this very fact and
the way that different cultures interact
that make up Spain today he hopes that
the far rights will not gain more
influence if people were to see us on
the street and say look they want to
reconquer our Andaluz he would of course
be hurtful
giannis thought it would mean that the
propaganda has worked and people are
scared they made that it's a it's a mule
a hunting but in the end he says the far
right is shooting itself in the foot
Islam's legacy has had an impact not
only on Muslims but on all Spaniards and
a bit of this culture remains in each of
them even far-right extremists